my dad was called sean brady he was 55
and he was a key worker so he worked at
the heinz factory in wigan and he'd
worked there for 34 years and he was the
kind of worker where he'd not had a day
off six since i was three and i'm 25 now
he was so committed to his job
he was so committed to me and to my
younger sister he would give me the
clothes off his back if it thought he
would make me happy he was
such a brilliant guy
that thought so little of himself and i
don't think he ever would have imagined
that his name would be mentioned by the
leader of the opposition in the house of
parliament
it's just
so heartbreaking
that the reason his name is mentioned is
because he died
yeah you can go into as little or as
much detail as as you want in this we're
just looking at a few pictures of of of
your dad um
but take us back to that time in 2020
when of course he he he did contract
covert and this was all pre-vaccination
pre-antivirals all of the successes that
the prime minister listed at the
dispatch box today he did contract
covert and like so many others
unfortunately lost his life to it
yeah we think he caught it on his way to
work because he used public transport
he was so proud to be considered a key
worker he had a letter from his employer
that he carried around in his pocket
um that he would show people proudly he
was considered a key worker he was so so
proud of that but it cost him his life
he
went into hospital on the 2nd of april
unable to breathe which we just couldn't
comprehend because he went to the gym
three four times a week he was super fit
you know really healthy
and within three days we got a call on a
sunday night to say
you need to say goodbye to your dad over
the phone because we're putting him in a
coma and he probably won't wake up
and the last thing that he said to me
when he was alive was that he was sorry
that he was making me worry
not that he was scared not that he
thought he was going to die that he was
sorry to me and my sister for making us
worry and that's the sort of guy that i
lost
he died after 42 nights on a ventilator
in a coma
me and my sister were allowed in for his
final moments we could only touch him
through ppe
and he was completely unconscious so he
had no idea that we were there when we
let them turn his ventilator down and
watched him die
i will for those to be the last words he
said yeah good man your dad a good man
but
so it happens on the 20th of may where
we now learn the prime minister was in
attendance and whatever you want to call
was going on in the back gardens of
number 10 but but he was there on that
day you were you were
applying for your father's death
certificate
yeah we um were getting his death
certificate signed um the only thing on
there was covered because he had no
underlying health conditions
we were um
shopping for a care package for his icu
nurses because speaking to them on the
phone for those 42 nights we could tell
they were not taking care of themselves
they also asked us for amazon vouchers
from donations we got in dad's name
because they had no ppe and that's the
only way they were buying it
so why families like mine grieving
families
were bereaved were alone away from their
loved ones and their friends having lost
a guy like dad
orris johnson spent 25 minutes at a
garden party where 100 people have been
invited to bring their own booze and
enjoy the weather
you met him
at dining street before of course all of
this this emerged i mean what was the
the nature of your discussion what did
the prime minister say to you in in that
garden
so i met him in the exact same garden
where he'd hosted this party on the 20th
of may the year before which to me seems
callous and cruel to host bereaved
people in the same garden
and i met him i told him my dad's story
and i showed him a picture of my dad on
a ventilator which i'd never shown to
anybody before
hoping that if he saw it he would take
what we were asking for which was a
public inquiry into the handling of
cobit more seriously
i hoped that i'd got through to him
he apologized
which i didn't need i needed him to take
the public inquiry seriously
what he did say to me which will stick
with me is that he'd done everything he
could to save my dad he'd followed the
science but most importantly he'd
followed the rules
and he must have heard the date that i
told him 16th of may 2020 the day dad
passed away
and in his head he must have thought
that was four days before our party
so it just changes the entire nature of
our meeting
because today he apologized for
attending that party and apologize for
what had happened on his watch
but if he had anything about him any
sort of decency integrity moral
authority which i think he's completely
lacking
he would have admitted to this party to
me then or before he was caught
so so what then anna did do you make of
what we heard from the prime minister
today and and i say it not to challenge
you but just to try
just to keep our viewers
give the proper context to our viewers
he as you mentioned he issued an apology
he said in direct response to secure
stamina that he sympathized deeply with
your situation i wonder if you accept
those sympathies and those apologies
from the prime minister today i
i don't accept those sympathies and i
don't accept that apology i think that
an apology made under duress is not
meant at all if he'd admitted to it
before he was caught then perhaps it
would mean something but an apology
isn't just words you have to accept the
consequences of your action and the
responsibilities that you have as the
leader of this country i'm a trainee
teacher and when i tell a people that
they've done something wrong they're
angry not that they've done something
wrong but only that they've been caught
and that's what the prime minister
reminded me of today he looked furious
at being caught not at what he'd done
ah well hannah i'm sure your dad i would
be very proud of the eloquence with
which you've spoken this evening um anna
brady thank you so much for joining us
really appreciate it
thank you